PROFESSOR: Now we're ready to
prove the law of large numbers
and while we're at it, to
get a quantitative version,
which will be the
basis for theory
of sampling an estimation.
So let's remember that
the law of large numbers
says that if you
have n independent,
identically distributed
random variables with mean mu
and we let An b their average,
then for every positive number
delta, the probability that the
average differs from the mean
by more than delta goes to 0 as
the number of trials increases.
Remember, that means
that if you tell me
what you think
close means and what
you think very likely means,
then I can guarantee that
by doing enough trials, the
likelihood that the mean will
be that close to the average
will be outside the tolerance
is as small as you
thought small should be.
And we're ready for the proof.
But in the proof,
there's one extra fact
that we're going to use that
we didn't explicitly mention,
which is that not only are
all of these random variables
identically distributed
and independent,
but we're actually
going to assume
that they have a variance.
Now, not every random variable
has a finite variance,
even if it has a finite mean.
In fact, there are random
variables that don't even
have finite means,
and we'll look at them
on the last day of class.
But so we're going
to explicitly assume
that all of these
random variables
have the same variance, namely
the standard deviation sigma
squared, and we'll be using
that fact in the proof.
Now, the first question
to ask is, what is
the expectation of the average?
And the expectation
of the average
is simply the expectation.
Let's prove that.
The expectation of the
average is by definition
the expectation of the
sum of the R's over n,
and by additivity
of expectation,
that's the sum of
the expectation
of each of the R's over n.
But each of them
has expectation mu,
so the numerator is n
mu and the n's cancel.
And sure enough, the average
has the same expectation
as each of the individual
variables, each of the trials.
Now, that [INAUDIBLE] let's
us apply the Chebyshev bound
to the random variable
An because now we
know what its mean is, and
its mean is independent of n.
We can apply Chebyshev
to the probability
that the average of n
trials differs from its mean
by more than delta.
And according to
Chebyshev, that's
bounded by the variance of the
average divided by n squared.
So I will have proved
the law of large numbers
if I can prove that the limit
as n approaches infinity
of the variance goes
to 0 because that means
that the right-hand side will be
going to 0 over delta squared,
namely going to 0, which is what
the law of large numbers says.
So we've reduced the proof
of the law of large numbers
to proving that the variance
goes to 0 as n approaches
infinity, where An
is the average of n
identically
distributed variables
with common mean mu and
standard deviation sigma.
Well, let's calculate the
variance of An where An, again,
is the average, the
sum of the R's over n.
And since we're
assuming independence
of the R's, the variance
sum rule, and it
just tells us that this is
the sum of the variances.
Now, if we factor out
the R-- 1 over n-- now,
this is a factor of 1
over times n this sum.
When we factor a constant
out of the variance,
it squares, so the denominator
here becomes n squared,
and that's critical.
And the numerator is the
sum of the n variances.
Now, each variance
is sigma squared
and we've got n of
them, so we wind up
with n sigma squared
over n squared,
which is, of course, equal
to sigma squared over n.
And sigma squared is a constant,
and n is going to infinity.
So sure enough,
the right-hand side
goes to 0 as n
increases, which is
all we needed to do to conclude
the weak law of large numbers.
Now, if we go back and
look at this proof,
the only thing that it
used about the R's was
that they had the same
mean, mu, and they actually
had the same variance,
sigma squared,
and the variances added.
That was the key
step in the proof,
that the variance of
the sum of the R's was
equal to the sum
of the variances.
Now, additivity of
variances only requires
pairwise independence and didn't
even require the hypothesis
that they were
mutually independent,
and it didn't require
the previous proof
that we went
through-- did not ever
use the fact that the R's
had the same distribution,
that they may not be
identically distributed.
It was sufficient that
they have the same mean,
and we can summarize
what really proved.
When we thought we were proving
the law of large numbers,
we actually proved a
precise quantitative theorem
that says that if
R1 through Rn are
pairwise independent
random variables
with the same finite mean
mu and variant sigma squared
and we let An be the average
of those n variables,
then the probability that the
average differs from the mean
by more than delta is less
than or equal to this definite
number that we derived, 1 over n
times sigma over delta squared,
and this was what we
previously proven.
We thought we were just proving
the law of large numbers.
We actually got this much
tighter quantitative theorem.
Now, what this tells us here
is that now if you tell me
what delta is and you tell me
how small you want this to be,
well-- I'm given sigma and
you give me the delta that you
specified, and if you tell me
how small you want this to be--
I will know how
big an n to choose.
So this tells me how
big a sample I need,
how many tries I
have to make in order
to get the probability that
the mean is within a specified
tolerance delta as
small as you specified,
and that is our independent
sampling theorem.
That's why it's called
independent sampling,
because we now know how big a
sample is needed to estimate
the mean of any random
variable with any desired
tolerance and any desired
probability, where of course
the various has to be
finite, the tolerance
has to be positive--
tolerance is delta--
and the probability
has to be less than 1.